why are redditors up in arms over Ryan
Gosling's depiction of Ken in the new
Barbie movie I'm actually not sure over
on Reddit some fun suck issue with
Gerber's vision of Barbie on an official
discussion thread as one user wrote
comedy was pretty good and Ryan Gosling
carried hard however the message feels
extremely confused here the film very
obviously tries to express topics such
as feminism patriarchy power and gender
roles however I feel like the way these
themes are addressed are strange another
Reddit to express a similar sentiment
saying the message of empowering women
was so incredibly on the nose and
preachy that I started to think it was a
satire of a satire so what's the point
of all this the point is that as we
strive for True equality the
marginalized must be given control over
the structures of power in Barbie land
the Barbies possess the power of the
real world's patriarchy and in the
aftermath of Kingdom they agree that Ken
should have as many rights as women do
in the real world